[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 اننا
نجنا اخباريون خاص ومتنوع وبيقاع سريعا
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين
المرشد والنظام امام حرب الجبهات الاربعه
الوقت والتاريخ ضدهما ويندران بحرب
الاهليه
اغنى افقر قاره في العالم هدف للجميع وان
اختلفت الطرق واشنطن وبريطانيا تسعيان
لتدارك الغفله وفي ملفات الساعه 60
سيليكون فالي صيني ازرار تيك توك خطرا ان
يحدقوا بامريكا الهاتف الجديد نصيحه
تغييراتنا جذريه في كاس العالم بسبب
المهاجرين انجاز المغرب التاريخي ليس محت
صدفه
[موسيقى]
كسر طاوعتها جدران الخوف في ايران بات
منطق العيش بكرامه او الموت بشرف هو
الشعار وكل ما يتوغل هذا المنطق لشريحه
ايرانيه اكبر وتتزايد العقوبات الغربيه
تلجا السلطات لصناعه الخوف وزياده القمع
النتيجه اسرار اكبر على اسقاط النظام تعود
على اخماد المشاكل وليس حلها ولنا في
الانترنت دليل جديد الوسيله الوحيده لفتح
ممارسات السلطات والجيل زاد الشجاعه بما
يكفي صوته وصل الى العالم عبر بوابه مواقع
التواصل بدء مما حدثنا فالحبوبه
يعني يريد حجما كاملا ويتهم الاعداء بصنع
برامج لرفع الحجب لكن الشعب هو من يقوم
بذلك وسنتطرق للامر بعد قليل ما نتيجه هذه
القيود هلا اتوقف الايرانيون على الاحتجاج
هل هناك فائده من الحجم الاضرار كبيره على
الاقتصاد الخسائر بالف المليارات 11 مليون
ايراني يتقاضون دخلهم من تطبيق انستغرام
فقط خسائر كل ساعه من قطع الانترنت تعادل
45 مليار تومان والعهده على صحيفه سترى
صبح
هذه الخسائر تحديدا تنقلنا الى نقطتنا في
نفس الاتجاه الاحتجاجات وخرجت اصلا بسبب
مقتل ممساميني لكنها باتت الاطول منذ
1979 لاسباب اضافيه جوهريه بالطبع الاوضاع
والمعيشيه صعبه الاقتصاد المتدهور العمله
المتساويه سعر صرفها مقابل الدولار ارتفع
الى اكثر من
380,000 ريال رقم قياسي والسبب وراءه
بينظر النظام هو المحتاجون
ظاهريا يبدو الامر صحيحا الاحتجاجات شلت
القطاعات لكن النظام هو المسؤول عن
اجراءاته خسائر وحجب الانترنت اكبر مثال
كما ان العمله هوت بسبب عقوبات دوليه
جديده فرضت بسبب قمع الاحتجاجات اصلا
وهكذا توضح بل مباركه طبعا اذا انتقلنا
الحرب الاوكرانيه سنجده سببا اه اخر ادعم
روسيا بالمسيرات
اخرى على ايران مزيدا من تدهور الاقتصاد
شهر مارس الماضي يضحك ايضا فرضيه النظام
سعروا العمله الايرانيه انخفض وقتها مقابل
العملات الاجنبيه باكثر من 40% وانتشرت
منذ ذلك الحين ظاهره مقايضه المواد
الغذائيه بالاثاث المنزلي والمقتنيات
الشخصيه وذلك في بلد يحتل المرتبه الثالثه
عالميا من حيث اعلى معدل تضخم حقيقي
للمواد الغذائيه في الاشهر الثمانيه
الاولى من 2022 اي قبل الاحتجاجات اربعه
وثمانون في المائه هذه ارقام البنك الدولي
وتركيبه ازمات مع احتجاجات لا يخمد
لايرانها العنف قد تمثل وصفه حرب اهليه
وقت ثالث داخلي وهنا التحليل لمؤسسه مؤسسه
عيسى
المخصصه بالابحاث ومقرها ولايه وسكانسن
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
مقزومه خائفا وغاض بيتحركوا في كل
الاتجاهات لكن حيز الفاعليه لاسكات صرخه
الحريه والحياه والمراه من قبلهما يضيق
النظام المعزول السائمه الداخل وسطوته
بالصبغه المتشدده والديكتاتوريه التي
تفرضها العباءه ترهقه اليوم روتينيه احراق
الرموز او الصور وانسيبيه اسقاط العمامه
حتى في عمقه الفارسي واكثر ما يخيفه هو
كسر الخوف ومشاهده سلاح في الشوارع بايد
المحتاجين
فاقده داخليا وبعد تهمه التخوين بالاجنده
الاجنبيه يحمل المتظاهرين الان مسؤوليه
الضغوط والعقبات ويلجاوا الى الاعدامات
العلنيه منها على هاتف الحركه المنخفضه
وتخيفها ولنا وقفه مع الاعدامات لكن
السؤال الان لماذا لا يقدم النظام الخائف
تنازلات وكيف يفكر
يعلم ما جيدا كالمحتاجين انه لا يمكن
اختزاله الازمه وكان شرطه الاخلاق هي
المشكله وحلها هو الحل بل تكشف بسبب
الفوضى داخل نخبه نظام ان ذلك لا يعدو
كونه تكتيكا للاستعاده السيطره قانون
الزاميه الحجاب لن يسقط حتى وان تتم
مراجعته في البرلمان الان القانون هو احد
الاسس الرئيسيه للنظام وغطاء الراس ايقونه
ثورته في
1979 التنازل عنه بنظره سيكون بوابه
الحريه للايرانيين الشباب منهم الذين تكشف
مطالبهم شيخوخه الثوره الخشيه الاكبر من
مطالب لم تبدا مع الانتفاضه سبتمبر
يعلم النظام منذ 2018 على الاقل ان نسبه
تاييد غطاء الراس قدم خفضت في السنوات
التي اعقبت الثوره من 85% الى
35% نسبه يمكن اسقاطها وموازاتها بتاييد
النظام بيحدداته يعلم ونعلم ذلك لان
الارقام رسميه جاءت في بحثا واستطلاعا
لمركز ابحاث البرلمان الايراني ومن
البرلمان تاتين المؤشرات عضو اللجنه
الثقافيه فيها الحليف الديني لخامن احسان
جلالي يتباهى بالقدره القمعيه للنظام
وقياده المرشد لاكثر من 190.000 عنصرا في
الحرس الثوري وعشرات الالاف من المسيج
المكلفين بغرس الخوف بين الشعب والمفارقه
لم تجدي هذه الاعداد ونفعا الاعتراف قائد
الحرس الثوري حسين سلامه وذلك خلال ج في
نقاش امام المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
اخفاق امنيون ضخم اذن يخفي خلفه اخفاقا
اخر مكافحه التغيير والتغيير اجن ما يخيف
الانظمه الشموليه ويهدد وجودها وهنا ايران
خسرت حربها الثقافيه
خذي المرشد الثقافيه كما اسمه تسرب الى
داخل اسوار المجتمع المنغلق قصرا
بتوجيهاته والانترنت عدوه الاول حجمه لم
يدفع برامج في بي ان او فك الحظر والتشفير
تباع في البقاله بحسب النائب الايراني
ببيح الله اعظم سرداوي ومن البقاله يفتح
فضاء التهديدات على بوابه الحرب الناعمه
التي حذر المرشد من تدميرها لايران
محاربتها تستوجب التاثير على الايرانيين
بدءا من عقولهم وهنا تاكيد اخر على ان حل
شرطه الاخلاق لم يكن سوى اجراء شكليا في
منظومه تمثل فيها دور ضابط ايقاع ايقاع
البسيج التي اكلت اليها مهمه التركيز على
التهديدات الثقافيه 20 الف رجل دين اعين
في 20000 دائره مهمتهم التدريب الديني في
رياض الاطفال الى الجامعات وهكذا يتفاخر
محمد رضا نقدي القائد السابق للبسيج
تعليمات هؤلاء تسير بالتوازي مع خطه
التحول الديموغرافي احلال من يتعارض فكريا
وقوميا مع النظام في شريحه المفضله له
الفارسيه بالضروره يشجع النظام ابنائه
واحفاده على الانجاب وليس بالمعدل الطبيعي
الذي فرضه منذ ثمانينات محددا متوسط
الطفلين لكل عائله القاده العسكريون
يشجعون عضوات الحرس الثوري على انجاب خمسه
اطفال على الاقل للحصول على مكافات تقاعد
مبكر اسهم المجانين في المؤسسات الوطنيه
والف دولار في شكل قرود بعد انجاب الطفل
الثالث
وبعد كل هذا جاءت المفاجاه
الحاضنه انتفضت ومزقه الروايه الانتفاضه
ليست كرديه مالوفه يسوقها التاريخ الطويل
من القمع ضد دعاه الانفصال تبريز شيراز
علام همدان
وقزوين ازنجان وكرمان وحتى قم العاصمه
الدينيه ومنبع الايدولوجيا كلها ذات
الاغلبيه الفارسيه هتفت كغيرها من المناطق
الكرديه الاذريه وغيرها بالموت لخامنئي
الموتور والرد كان تعليق المشانق والضحيه
مجيده
لوالدته سيبقى سيبقى شنقهم حرقه باغتها
عبرت عنها على قبرها
[موسيقى]
يقاتل وحكمه باطل هكذا تقول حكم الخائف
ايضا
الخوف سقوط الولاء
مع السلطه ومسقط راس خامنئي رساله واضحه
للعمق الفارسي لكن رهن وارد الذي استند
الحكم اليه بناء على هذا المقطع غير
الواضح بقتل عنصرين من المسير كان ثاني
المحتاجين على مشنقه النظام سبقه محسن
الشيكاري باربعه ايام اصاب احد العناصر
بجروح فاعدم وهناك العشرات وغيرهما هناك
هناك صدريات 23 سنه
كسر هاتفها بسيجي
يسقط هو النظام صوتا 22
عن كم نتحدث 20 الف تقريبا بالاعتقال 500
شخص بالقتل والعشرات بالانتحار
الشوارع امنيه يخلق ما تبقى من حريه او
هكذا يظن النظام
اكلنا المراه الحياه الحريه
[تصفيق]
واهلي
الدكتور محمد اميري مقدم رئيس منظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه اهلا بك اذا لما يطفئ
كل العنف الاعتقالات القتل الاعدام نيران
هذه الانتفاضه وحتى الان الاقتصاد مازوم
بالتالي العمله تتهاوى وايضا هناك عقوبات
متزايده متى يفهم النظام ومتى يمكن ان
يقدم التنازلات
حبيبي
[موسيقى]
النظام الايراني خلال 43 عاما مضت بات ان
نظاما يمثل فئه قليله فقط من المجتمع
الايراني نفسه
لان ايمان واحده من المطالب الاساسيه
للشعب الايراني هي المسائله
واذا ما كان النظام مسائلا فيجب ان يستجيب
لكافه الجرائم التي ترتكبها خلال 43 عاما
وهم غير قادرون على غير قادرين على
الفائده في ذلك فليس لديهم كبار سوى القمع
والقتل والسجون
العقوبات وهناك من يقول ان ايران لا تفهم
لغه العقوبات ولكن من جهه اخرى لو نظرنا
الى العقوبات فان اقصى العقوبات على ايران
تكون هي العقوبات الثانويه التي تؤثر
مباشره على السيوله وبالتالي على تصدير ان
يفقدها الى الخارج هذه هي نقاط الضغط على
ايران متى يمكن ان يتحرك المجتمع الدولي
بهذا الاتجاه
همم
يو ار رايت
الشيء الوحيد الذي قد يكون له اثر على
سلوكيات النظام الايراني هو الضغط
سواء الضغط من الداخل من قبل الشعب وكذلك
الضغط الدولي
وعندما نتحدث عن العقوبات
فانا نحن نريد ان تكون العقوبات موجهه
بشكل مباشر
ضد الحرس الثوري وهؤلاء الذين يطلقون
الرصاص على المتظاهرين وكذلك القضاء
الايراني الذي هو جزء من هذا النظام
القمعي وكذلك المرشد الاعلى
وكافه الاسس التي هم مسؤول عنها هذه
الاموال تستخدم بشكل مباشر الشعب الايراني
40 عاما
لو
اظهر السلطات الايرانيه اي نوع من المرونه
بالاتجاه الايجابي فكان ذلك بسبب الضغوط
وبالتاكيد اعتقد بانه في مرحله ما سوف
يجبرون على وقفي عمليات القمع هو احد
الاسباب التي لا يستطيع النظام الايراني
قتلى السكان كما كان يفعلون الماضي قبل
الاربعين عاما لانه كان لدينا نتظاهرات
حينها هو لان التكلفه السياسيه
جدا ولا يستطيع ان يتحمله
كما شاهدنا ايضا مع
رهنا ورد وهناك ايضا ما يتعلق بهذه
المحاكمات يعني بحسب صحيفه اعتماد تقول ان
محاميه المتهمين هم يعني يتبعون للنظام
وانهم حتى في دفاعهم عن المتهمين بنظر
النظ ان كانوا يقدمون على اصابه عنصر من
البسيج او حتى هناك جناح لا ترقى لمستوى
السجن حتى ولكن في نهايه المطاف يحكم
عليهم بالاعدام هذه ايضا تضع الكثير من
الضغوط يفترض على النظام الايراني في هذه
المرحله بموازاه قتل المحتاجين في الشوارع
واستطيع ان اقول انما يقومون به
الانعدامات او احكام الاعدام هو التصعيد
لعمليات العنف المستخدمه ضد الشعب
الايراني خلال الاشهر ثلاثه الماضيه
قاتلوا بين
400 شخص على الشوارع سي سي
طفلا اما الان فقام بتصعيد عمليات العنف
وبداوا او بداوا بالتخطيط لقتل المساجين
وكما قلت ايضا ليس لدينا عنايه واجبه او
محاكمات عادله فهذه الاعدامات
قبل بعد 23 يوم من اعتقالهم فهذا قاتل من
دون محاكمه عادله وليس حكم بالموتى
والاعدام
القويه
حملت اعدامات واسعه جدا وهذه خطه النظام
الشخصين وهم يقيمون رده الفعل وانا سعيد
دوليه كبيره في الخارج وكذلك في الداخل
ولم تؤدي الى نهايه
التظاهرات حتى في زاهدان ان هناك احتجاجات
وظاهرات وحملوا اسم ماجد طيب يبدو بان
النظام لا يحقق اهدافهم التي تكمن في
اعدام الاشخاص البث الرعب بين الشعب ومنعه
من التظاهر بل بدا يعطي نتائج عكسيه
للنظام وحتى هناك
عامه في التاسعه عشر وحتى 21 من الشهر
الحالي شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من اوسلو
الدكتور محمود امي مقدم رئيس منظمه حقوق
الانسان الايرانيه
غادرت افريقيا بقواتها وابقى عملاتها في
الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في تحركاتنا لكسب
الحديقه الخلفيه او انتاعها
ربما انها تاخرت
50 زعيما ومسؤولا افريقيا بل كونها
الثانيه التي تعقد بعد قمه اليتيمه تراسها
باراك اوباما في 2014
استراتيجيه امريكيه جديده وهي التي اعلنت
عنها في اغسطس الماضي لتوجهها لتتوجها
عفوا بقمه منحت فيها القاره السمراء خمسه
55 مليارا اي تقريبا مليار دولار لكل دوله
تاخرت واشنطن التي تسبقها الصين حتى
بمعرفتك ما تحتاجه افريقيا وسنتطرق لذلك
بالتفصيل بعد قليل 60 مليار دولار خطها
بكين في قمه 2018 استثمارات ومساعدات
الماليه الحقدتها بتنازلا كريم في وعشرين
حين تخلت عن عشره مليارات دولار ديون
لافريقيا ومنحتها مليارات اللقاحات بصفه
مجانيه لدعممها في مواجهه الجائحه
للمفارقه ليست كافيه مع عامل الحرب
الاوكرانيه الذي يهدد افريقيا بمجاعه تحذر
منها الامم المتحده كما تبقي القاره وتبقى
متعطشه للمزيد من التنميه مهما كان المالح
وكيفما كانت التقاطعات الامنيه والعسكريه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه بين القوه الموجوده
ومن هنا دخل لاعب جديد قوي ظاهريا لكنه في
مازقنا يدفعه لاخراج ورقه
سندس
ربما طرب بريطانيا او الحزب المحافظ
للدقاء الفرصه الثاني حاليا لتحقيق رؤيه
بريطانيا العالميه المسار الخاص بعد
بردسات الذي سيمنحها القدره على
الاستقلاليه ولو جزئيه عن اوروبا اقتصاديا
سياسيا وامنيا ورؤيه باتت اكثر الحاحا
خاصه وان التقارب المامول مع واشنطن بما
قد يعوض التراجع في العلاقات مع اوروبا لم
يكتمل الولايات المتحده عادت النظر بي
اولوياتها واهتماماتها الان تحاولوا لندن
تاسيس سياسه خارجيه جديده لها هذا صحيح
ولم تخصها بافريقيا فقط ربما الدول
الافريقيه مهما كانت استراتيجيه لندن تبقى
بالنسبه للقاره مستعمرا سابقا ومستغلاوات
هو شكل من اشكال اعاده التموضع مهما تعددت
تسميته في وجه الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
من جهه وتوسع نفوذ الصين التي يصفها ريش
سوناك بالتحدي النظامي من جهه
بريطانيا تريد بناء علاقات مع بلدان
متزايده التاثير معظمها في امريكا
اللاتينيه واسيا وايضا القاره الافريقيه
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني زار خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه كينيا واثيوبيا وعدا
بمزيد من الاستثماراتها فيها تنطلق هذه
الزيارات مما سماها كلابيلي البراجماتيه
التطلعيه حيث يرى انا الاستثمار في
البلدان الافريقيه الرئيسيه يوفر فوائد
ضخمه للمملكه المتحده والى جانب الدعم
عقدت بريطانيا منذ البراكسد اتفاقيات في
شارع حراء مع 07/10 دوله افريقيه قيمتها
تفوق 18 مليار جنيه كذلك رئيس جنوب
افريقيا زار بريطانيا الشهر الماضي معلنا
شراكه بين البلدين في مجالي الصحه والعلوم
كما تناولت المحادثات التجاره والاستثمار
فيما يبدو انها كلها تاتي محاولات لتعزيز
التعاون بين بريطانيا وشركاء غير
التقليديين خاصه بعد اعلان سوناك نهايه
العهد الذهبي مع الصين
نعود الى اهمال الولايات المتحده في
القاره السمراء والتي ظهرت منه ملامح
كثيره عبر السنين مثلا في عهد ترامب
دبلوماسيان بعد المناصب بالاكثر اهميه
كانت شاغره وعسكريه ان اقول لصا عدد
القوات الامريكيه لمكافحه الارهاب في
افريقيا بنسبه 25%
اهمال الدالي نجمه الصين التي لديها
254 مليار دولار حجمه مبادلات تجاريه مع
القاره اربعه اضعاف ارقام امريكا ولديها
استثمارات فتنتين و50 دوله افريقيه من اصل
اربع وخمسين اذا شراكه ممتده 2002
ظهر لفظ 17 دوله افريقيه ادانت الحرب على
اوكرانيا في الامم المتحده وهي الموجوده
عسكريه عبر وتص ونصفه حاجيات القاره من
السلاح نفوذ بكين وموسكو لا يتعرضان
بمناسبه الرقم 17 فهو لافت اسقطت الصين
الى جانب الديون التي ذكرناها في 2020
اسقطت ديون اخرى في 2022 وكانت مستحقه على
17 دوله افريقيه بعد اتهامات من واشنطن
باغراق الافارقه بالديون بكين هي اكبر
مقرضا للدول الافريقيه بالطبع واشنطن تخشى
اذا النفوذ الصيني ولذلك تحاول العوده
قلقه ربما من تكرار سيناريو وجزر سليمان
في الاطلسي الصين الشيده مئه ميناء في
افريقيا الكثير منها يطل على المحيط
الاطلسي
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه التي تحدثنا عنها
قبل قليل جاءت بعد 16 عاما من اعلان بكين
استراتيجيه مشابهه فرق الاهتمام واضح
تنفيذ الاستراتيجيه
ظهر في القمه الافريقيه في واشنطن وفي
المقابله الصين ومنذ عام 2000 تقيم كل
ثلاث سنوات
التعاون الصينيه الافريقيه وهنا فرقا اخر
طلب المؤسسات والشركات الامريكيه التابعه
للحكومه او الخاصه مثل شركه مايكروسوفت
والتبادل التجاري دورا مهما في العلاقه
بين الولايات المتحده والدول الافريقيه
التي تحاول واشنطن اعاده ضبط علاقاتها
معها من خلال عقد القمه الثانيه بعد قمه
2014 فمن ذلك الحين تهمت السياسه
الامريكيه بانها اقل طموحا واقرب الى
الاهمال الحميد كما وصفت تجاه افريقيا في
غضون ذلك اصبحت الصين الشركه التجاريه
الاول لافريقيا عبر الاسترادي وبناء الطرق
والموالع وزياده مساعدتها الخارجيه للقاره
فيما زادت روسيا من تدخلاتها الامنيه عبر
شركه باندر امر جعل العلاقات الافريقيه مع
الصين وروسيا تخدعوا للتدقيق الامريكيه
فيما يرى البعض ان التحدي الاكبر للرئيس
بايضا خلال القمه اقناعه القاده الافرقه
بان ادارته مستعده لتقديم المشاركه
دبلوماسيه واقتصاديه قويه وانه سيلتزم
بالموارد اللازمه لمنافسات الصين
اغنى قاره في العالم بالثروات وافكرها
اقتصادا افريقيا مطمعا طبعا والوصول
للكنوزها الطبيعيه هدف لكن الطرق
ان تميز نفسها عن الدول الغربيه
والمستعمرين السابقين تريد المنفعه
المتبادله بدلا من الارتكان الى وسائل
المنوي المنح سياسته سياسه تبدو ناجحه
علمت ان بكين يتوقع ان تجني من افريقيا
440 مليار دولار بحلول 2025 جنوب افريقيا
اثيوبيا في المقدمه مبلغ يعادل نصف قيمه
عرس الميزانيه الخاصه ببكينا لهذا العام
تريليون دولار وهنا تظهر ضروره تغيير
واشنطن السياستها من علاقه صفه الابويه
الى علاقه شراكه والمستفيد الاول هنا هو
دول القاره قادتها يريدون علاقات جيده مع
كلن من الصين وامريكا لكن سياستها بكين
بدات تتغير اصلا مؤخرا تجاه لعسكره
السياسه الخارجيه وواشنطن قلقه من ثمان
النفوذ منذ 2017 لدى الصين قاعده عسكريه
لوجستيه في دره تاج القرن الافريقي وقلبي
مشروع الحزام والطريق في جيبوتي التي تعد
بوابه قناه السويس التي يمر عبرها عبرها
10% من صادرات النفط العالميه وعشرين في
المئه من السلع التجاريه
نافعا اخر لواشنطن لاستدراك الغفله عن
القاره القاعده لا تقع فقط على واحده من
الممرات الاستراتيجيه الرئيسيه وهي اكثر
ممرات الشحنه البحريه ازدحاما بل تبعد
ايضا السته اميال فقط عن قاعده عسكريه
امريكيه رئيسيه وهنا هو من جيبوتي يظهر
اللاعب اخر مهم تراجعات نفوذه في القاره
والصور والنمطيه مختلفه تماما عن الصين
نتحدث عن فرنسا تمتلك في جيبوتي اهم واقدم
قاعده عسكريه لها في القاره فرنسا البلد
الاوروبي الاكثر ارتباطا ليس بجبوتي فقط
بل بافريقيا كامله عقودا من الاستعماري
والاستغلال غادرت بقوتها لكنها باقيه من
وراء الستار بعملاتها الفرانك الافريقي
بالعوده لعام
1945 فرنسا قررت انشاء عمله موحده تدير
بها مستعمراتها في افريقيا حكم الواقع
الاستعماري اينما كان جاء الاستقلال بعدها
لبعض الدول نعم تخلصت من الاستعمار بحلول
عام 1960 لكنه كان اكذوبه الامر لم يتغير
14 بلدا افريقيا يواصل استخدام الافريقي
حتى
دول افريقيا رغم نجاحها في تشكيل الاتحاد
الاقتصادي في
1975 الا ان كل المشاريع الانفصال المالي
عن باريس ذهبت هباءا كيف تستفيد فرنسا اذا
من هذا الامر البنك المركزي الفرنسي يطبعو
الفرانك مقابل رهن الافارقه ل 50% من
احتياطاتها النقديه ملايين الدولارات
مجمده في باريس وبالتالي الدول الافريقيه
الفقيره مضطره لتحويل اربع حصادراتها الى
اليورو اولا وهذا ما يساهم في سد العصر
الماليه الفرنسيه وحتى فوائده الاموال
المدعه لا تحولها فرنسا نقدا نقبل تمول
بها صناديق استثمارات الفرنسيه في افريقيا
يبقى سؤال اخر لماذا لم تتخلص ادول غربي
افريقيا من عمله الاستعمار فرنسا لن تقبل
بخساره النفوذ مين لن انشات عملتها لكن
باريس طبعه اموالا مزوره لتدمير عملتها
الجديده والعهده على كتاب الاسلحه الخفيه
لافريقيا الفرنسيه مثال اخر في توغو
رئيسها الاسبق انتقد الفرانك الافريقي
والنتيجه كانت اغتياله عام
1963 اين داخل السفاره الامريكيه ومن كان
المتهم الاول الاستخبارات الفرنسيه وذلك
باعتراف احد المنفذين
وجه النعسكري واخر سياسي دبلوماسي وبالطبع
هناك التنافس المالي المصرفي الفضائي
والنووي من اين نبدا واين ننتهي حين نتحدث
عن التنافس الامريكي الصينيه ليس فقط في
افريقيا كما كنا نقول قبل قليل العملاقاني
يتبارزاني في كل المجالات تقريبا
من هذه المجالات او يترقبها ربما اخر
الساحه اخرى كبيره ليست بحر الصين الجنوبي
ومسرحه ايوان المحكوم بالكثير من الوقت
والتاجيل المدروس والتعقيدات العسكريه
والجيو السياسيه ولا حتى القاره الافريقيه
التي ذكرناها قبل قليل فساحه المعنيه
تتزاحم بارقام
لنقرب الصوره اكثر بمجهر الساعه 6:00
الحرب
التكنولوجيه وما اشرسها هو
والجيل الخامس او 5 جي عنوان عريض لنقترب
اكثر
قواعد البيانات نعم اقتربنا كثيرا
مشاهدينا نعم نتحدث عن الخصوصيه وهنا
المجال واسع ويتعلق بالسريه التي تخترقها
الصين والولايات المتحده بالجواسيس نعم
هذا نمط وهناك انماطم اخرى ومنها النقره
وتخيلوا حين تتحول النقره في مساله امن
قومي
كيف لاكبر ناقلا للانترنت ان اي يحارب
باقوى اسلحته القوه الناعمه ومن الصعوبه
بل المستحيل ان يتنازل اراعي الثوره
التكنولوجيه عن عرش العالمي الانترنت كما
نعرفه اليوم وهو جوجل جوجل ستور واندرويد
لشركه الفابات فيسبوك وانستغرام وواتساب
وهناك امازون تويتر سناب شات وبطبع
مايكروسوفت هذا هو الانترنت امريكي
ان يكون الاكثر شعبيه عالميا ولا المفارقه
اصبح امرا واقعا وفي وقتا فاصف الازمات
بالسيليكون بالي عاصمه الابتكار التي شكلت
ورسمت عالم اليوم منذ ثلاثه عقود
وسناخذكم بالمناسبه في رحله في غدا اذا
وفي بكين المقابل سيليكون فالي اخر في
اصبح مركزه جدبان ل 20,000 كيانا
التكنولوجي ولكن باي حجم نتحدث عن ايرادات
تصلوا الى 800 مليار دولار سنويا ومن
الواحه الصينيه برز كابوس الامن الامريكي
نحن في 2019 في واشنطن البنتاجون يطلب من
افراد الجيش
وبعدها بسبعه اشهر يوليو 2020 تنتقل عدوى
الخوف الى شركه امازون ثم ثم الى المكتب
البيضاوي في البيت الابيض اغسطس 2020
اجتماع شهد حديده احتدام بحضور الرئيس
السابق بين بيتر نافارا المستشار التجاري
في البيت الابيض و ستيفن نيوتن وزير
الخزانه وعنوان الخلاف كيف سنتعامل مع تيك
توك فكره توم اندشن كانت اجبار دانس على
الصينيه على بيع تيك توك
نبارو اعتبر ذلك تساهل مع بكين اتفق ترامب
مع نافارو وايضا مع النوتشين في السادس من
اغسطس الرئيس الامريكي يوقع امرا تنفيذيا
بحضرتك
45 يوما في حال لم تقبل الشركه الصينيه
بيضا
تطبيقها للولايات المتحده لكن بينما
تشاهدون الساعه 60 الان هناك اكثر من 188
مليون مستخدم امريكي نشاط للتطبيق الذي
تصر واشنطن على انه خطر كما ان الحظر لم
يمنع الامريكيين من تنزيله 200 110 مره
ملايين مره ماذا يعني ذلك مشاهدينا يعني
انا التيك توك ايام تلقى قاعده بيانات
للاثنين واربعين في المئه من سكان
الولايات المتحده ونصفهم من البالغين ومن
وجهه نظر او بالاحرى اتهامات صناع بس
ياسين والامني الامريكيين فان هذه
البيانات ليست فقط في متناوليات الحكومه
الصينيه بالاستخدامها ومن ينفي الاتهامات
مؤسسوا الشركه جانج يمينك لكنه في الحقيقه
ومنذ 2019 يقع بين فكي كماشه الحكومه
الصينيه تفضل موت التطبيق على ان يتم
الاستحواذ عليه امريكيا عموما فكره
الاستحواذ انتهت بمجرد وصول ايضا الى
البيت الابيض ولا يعني ذلك انه اذارته غير
قلقين خاصه حين يستند الهاجس الى بيانات
الاستخبارات الاف بي اي يفتحوا قضيه
استخبارات مضاده متعلقه بالصين كل عشائر
10 ساعات وبطبع مدير المكتب كان يتحدث عن
تيك توك وجميع تطمينات الشركه لم تنفع حتى
ما تعهدها باحتفاضها ببيانات المستخدمين
فيرجيه ونسخه احتياطيه في سنغافوره بل
بحسب موقعي بسفيد الذي احدث بلبله على
مستوى الامن القومي الامريكي بعد حصوله
على تسريبات لمدراء تنفيذيين في تيك توك
فان مسؤوله الشركه في الصين كانوا لا
يزالوا يصلون الى بيانات المستخدمين
الامريكيين
بالعوده الى الشعبيه المغلقه الامريكيون
في صداره الاستخدام اليهم الاندونيسيون ب
99 ملايين مستخدم ثم
73,500,000 من البرازيل 51 مليون من روسيا
والمجموعه كله يتجاوز مليار مستخدم النشط
شهريا وهذه القواعد الجماهريه لا تملكها
سوى التطبيقات الامريكيه اذن عمليا تيك
توك وويتشات المصنف على انه ايضا الخطر
الصيني الثاني والمصمم من قبل شركه بايت
دانس ايضا المنافسين
لانستغرام الفيسبوك واتساب ويوتيوب ويحقل
الولايات المتحده ان تقلق من هذه الناحيه
على الاقل ولذلك هناك مشروع قانون لحظر
التطبيق
[موسيقى]
اكاديميه محمد السادس اللي كره القدم
السبب من اسباب نجاح المغرب في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كره القدم ما هي الرياضه
الاكثر شعبيه
في المونديال الاول عام 1930 خمسه في
المئه فقط من اللاعبين ولده خارج الدول
التي مثلتها رقم قليل مقارنه بالمونديال
الحالي لاعبني بكل سته لاعبين مثل دوله
غير التي ولد فيها
اختلاف في الارقام بين الماضي والحاضر لكن
التاثير ثابته في مونديال
1934 مثلا خمسه لاعبيننا مولودونا في
امريكا الجنوبيه ساعدوا ايطاليا بلد
اجدادهم للفوز في اول القامها الموندياليه
واحد هم اللي اسمه
اللقب الاول رفقه اوروبيه
لكن اليوم الهجره هجره الامس
لايطاليي الارجنتين لم تغير ولائقه واحدا
من افضل اللاعبين الارجنتيني الينا المسي
الذي ولد جده الاكبر في ريكان نات
ريكاناتي الايطاليه ريكانتي الايطاليه قبل
ان ينتقل الى الارجنتين عام
1893 ما اسباب هذه الظاهره اذن الاسباب
عده من بينها هجره اباء اللاعبين واجدادهم
في شكلها الطبيعي واسبابها المختلفه
المثال هنا يا كندا دوله مهاجرين فكان
منتخبنا مهاجرا بامتياز 22 لاعب من اصل
اربعه وعشرين اصولهم غير كنديه واشهرهم
الفونسو
للاجئين في غانا لابوين من ليبيا
سببا اخر وهو اللعب باسمي موطن الاباء
والاجداد وهذه النقطه تحديدا تضعفت خلال
العقدين الماضيين حقيقه تنعكس بوضوح في
حاله المغرب ثلاثه لاعبين فقط من مواليد
الخارج شاركوا مع المنتخب خلال اربع
بطولات لكاس العالم بين عام
1970 و
19980 لكن المغرب اليوم بها 14 لاعبا
موجودين في الخارج مثل اشرف حكيمي ولد
ونشا في مدريد واخرجت ضربته بالترجيحيه
اسبانيا تحديدا
تمثيل اللاعبين لدولي ابائهم واجدانهم لا
يقتصروا على المغرب فقط 32 لاعبا انهم
ولدوا في فرنسا دافعوا عن ثلاثه منتخبات
افريقيه تعود اصولهم لها في المونديال
الحاليه هذا الامر يجعل حتى بعض الاشقاء
يدافعون عن دول مختلفه
مونديال قطر ايضا دلائل وهنا نشاهد
الاخوين ايناكي وليامز ونيكو وليامز الاول
اختار ان ان يمثل ارض الاجداد غانا اما
الثاني ففضل تمثيل ارض الميلاد والنشراه
اسبانيا لا تاريخ المشترك بين غانا
واسبانيا ولكن هذه الحاله استثنائيه في
الاغلب تمثل المستعمرات السابقه خطا
امدادا كروي لمنتخباتي الدول المستعمره
واننا في فرنسا خير مثال معظم اللاعبينها
من اصول الدول استعملتها فرنسا سابقا
سينكر الدوره الكبيره الذي يلعبون نجوم
كره القدم من اصول المهاجره في المنتخب
الفرنسي فرنسا حصلت على كاس العالم مرتين
الاولى عام
1998 وساهم في ذلك النجم التاريخي زين
الدين زيدان وهو من اصول الجزائريه
والثانيه في عام 2018 حيث ضمت القائمه 14
لاعبا من اصول افريقيه من بين قائمه تضم
23 لاعبا كان ابرزهم كيليا وهو كاميرون
الاصل ورغم هذه الانجازات التي ساهم بها
المهاجرون الافارقه لا تساله هناك اصوات
وعارضه لهذا الامر وكان تسريب 2011 المثال
الاكبر على ذلك التسريب متناول قرارات
يفكر فيها الاتحاد الفرنسي للحكي من نسبه
اللاعبين من اصول عربيه وافريقيه بنسبه
30% كانت نتيجته هذا التسريب اقاله المدير
الفني للاتحاد الفرنسي وقتها فرنسا
السيناريو تكرر في هولندا استقلت عنها
دوله سورينام في
1975 لكنها لازالت والى اليوم تمثل منجم
مواهب لا ينضب للمنتخب البرتقالي القائمه
الطويله بلجيكا والكونغو البرتغال وكل من
الراس الاخضر وانجولا وموزمبيق الاخيرتان
قدمتا الفهد الاسمر اوزيبيو لكن الصوره
ليست ورديه دائما اختيار المنتخب الوطني
لا يتم براسك بقلبك وهكذا شرح حكيم زياش
قراره تمثيل وطنه الامه المغرب وليس
هولندا
التمييز ازمه اخرى اذرع المنتخبات
الاوروبيه ليست مفتوحه دائما لابناء
المهاجرين وعندما نفوز فنحن ابناء الدوله
لكن عندما نخسر فنحن ابناء المهاجرين
صرخه مشتركه اطلقها اكثر من نجم اذا
الانجاز التاريخي للمغرب بالوصول لنصف
نهائي المونديال لم يعتمد فقط على النجوم
المهاجره لاوروبا وهناك سبب هام اخر غابه
المغرب عن مندلي 2002 و2006 وخساره نهائي
البطوله الافريقيه عام 2004 غيابها جعل
التطور ضروره ولتظهر جوهره كره القدم
المغربيه بحسب وصف الاتحاد الدولي
اكاديميه محمد السادس في الرباط اكتشاف
المواهب الكرويه النتيجه ليست لحظيه ظهرت
على مدى السنوات والدليل احترافه عده
لاعبين في انديه اوروبيه كبيره مؤخرا
ومنهم الثلاثه تحديدا
تالق مع المغرب في المونديال عز الدين
ويوسف ان سيري ولا يفكر على مساحه تقدر
بنحو ثمانيه ترى هيك صارن انشئت هذه
الاكاديميه بتكلفه اتخطت 13 مليون دولار
وفقا المعايير الاوروبيه ولتكوين اللاعبين
تاهل الاكاديميه اللاعبين عبر وضع نظام
تربويا يجمع بين الرياضه والدراسه ايضا
ويساعد في ذلك المرافق والمعدات التي
تتوافق مع المعايير الاتحاد الدولي حيث
تتكون الاكاديميه منطقتين رئيسيتين
المساحه المفتوحه وتضم خمسه ملاعب رئيسيه
تتوزع بين ملاعب عشبا طبيعيه وملاعبهم
ملاعب صناعيه ومساحات خضراء واما القريه
الرياضيه فتضم خمسه ابنيه مخصصه للسكن
والتعليم والمركز الطبي
وتحتوي على خمسه اقسام منها المخصص للسكن
الذي يضم 30 غرفه مزدوجه واربعه فرديه
ومطبخ وقاعه الطعام لسعه 100 فرد هي ضخمه
يوجد اكاديميه ايضا قسم الطب الرياضي الذي
يضم صالات الالعاب الرياضيه وذلك فضلا عن
عياده طبيه وقاعه للعلاج الطبيعي وايضا
حوض للمعالجه من مياه معدني يعني
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بذلك نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
موضوعاتنا اليوم ووسط تتابعون غدا في
الساعه ستكون ايران تستنسخ تجربه اقتصادها
المتدهور في العراق عبر ميليشيا الحشد
الشعبي وفي الحرب الاوكرانيه هل اوقعت
روسيا نفسها في فخمه موت العمق مهدد
ومفتاح الجنوبي
في نهايه الساعه ابرز واحداث الساعه
بالصور من الان واحد تسال مقبله انا حنين
السوري وهذه الساعه 6:00
[موسيقى]